i recently read a uh article on npr
and it says it's for people in
relationships very interesting it says
married men and women who use
pornography are more likely to get
divorced than men and women who do not
researchers say corn is a driver in
making relationships worse
increasing the divorce risk
100
100 yes
why did you say that
um
it distorts the expectations i think
and you become addicted to things that
aren't in reality or at least are not
are not within the realms of what you
can do within your relationship
um
it's just it's dangerous man it's
dangerous it's bad it's don't do it
what do you mean you can do in your
relationship um
so
i guess it depends so if you if you if
you have a kink for
a particular thing or a particular angle
or particular whatever it is and your
partner can't do that or if you train
your brain to release or to feel
pleasure associated with a particular
visual
and in your relationship you may not be
able to not necessarily recreate but
event you're used to your partner's face
or body or whatever it is
but important is different people
different angles new things you're
learning
new things you're learning
when you're watching corn
but you're with the exact same person so
that alone is going to drive
some distance between you and your
partner and my in my
opinion do you think that's more of an
issue for women or for men
i think it could be for both for both
yeah do you think it has different
effects on men for women
yes
yeah what do you mean
why
well
sex for
a man
as i've been told by men
is
um
more animalistic
more
of a physical thing more of a
a release
um and less about
a con the connection
maybe not in a relationship and i'm not
saying that
a man cannot be intimate or cannot be
sensual or cannot be
all of the the airy fairy things that we
see in movies for example because
obviously men do and can
um but i believe for a female
um
it's just a different
expectation of what
the intimacy is going to be
i mean i've said this look men can have
sex with a hole in the wall i don't know
who's on the other side
and be fine
so i get you when you say that men can
see sex as animalistic
um but in relationships is is that the
same is that the same case
well not my relationship right okay some
relationships
and uh maybe
maybe the guys can can confirm or not
but i guess that there will be some
times or some occasions where
the sex with your partner
may not be about intimacy it may not be
about connecting with you right now it
might be i've had a very stressful week
and i just need a release
i might not be thinking about your
pleasure
i i personally think
women use corn
for pleasure
men do also
but i think a lot of men use corners and
escape
okay to
live out their
fantasies because more time
men will watch corn and their category
of choice will be the polar opposite to
their misses mm-hmm
they'll never watch someone else who
misses mm-hmm
and
men what we do is we tend to create a
fantasy in our own mind even if we're
chasing women we kind of like the chase
we like the story that we concoct in our
mind and that's what men tend to do with
corn they always go for the crazy wild
things or the things that the things
that excite us most
in life and in corn are the things that
we know we shouldn't be doing
[Music]
so then what if you're what if your
significant partner walks in on you
watching some kind of corn that she's
like that is so not me
like wouldn't she feel a certain way
about that i think a lot of women
feel away if their man's watching corn
anyway
so i have a stat for you that kind of
contradicts
what you're saying so cornhub stats
reveal women's search for more hardcore
genres 100
definitely
um
and 25 of uh consumers of corn via
cornhub are women
i've just seen more men get addicted to
it i think than women
um i don't necessarily know exactly why
i think it would tie in
to um
what he was saying about
fantasies like men
get
hooked on because that is something i've
seen i heard more i've heard more men
being saying like oh i'm addicted to
porn or i've just stopped watching it or
whatever they are at in their story with
with it
and um
i think that is just the fantasy part
that they uh
that they build up and when it comes to
women
it's so
unrealistic that i think it would be
like oh
a movie in a sense like i'm not about to
get this
big burly linebacker men to come through
my door on a normal day and it's just
something i think that women can
essentially disconnect big burly
linebacker is that what's on there
wait so categories viewed more by women
compared to matt i was just looking this
up um for women women view 200
more
they search for women on cornhub they
also search lesbian 155 percent more
than men
solo male 135 percent more hardcore 113
percent more rough sex 106 more
gang i don't even know is that that
can't be you know where i'm going with
that yeah that's fine
that can't be youtube friendly 104 more
bondage 91 more double penetration 87
more
69 more gay
percent more three some fifty four
percent more bisexual fifty three
percent more fistic what is fisting
it's where they dance and then
yeah yeah yeah
and then the most searched terms in the
us i don't know what the first one is
but i'm afraid to say it because i think
everyone's going to laugh at me do it a
hentai hentai okay what is that japanese
japanese anime japanese anime yeah wait
that's the most searched yeah oh my god
people have a thing for you remember
we're talking last week and we were
talking about the um dating apps what
did you say who's the most swept on
dating apps
asian women right yeah but women not the
anime
and hentai is very specific in the in
the in the in in how they portray
women's body why is stepmom in top ten
fantasy fantasies
so all of this stuff like in like if you
seriously if you have a partner and you
walked in and they were had a stepmom
corn video on like would you feel a
certain way about that person
no i don't
does he have a step mom
a good question
maybe he does and he fantasizes about
his stepmom
or maybe he just likes the fact that
there's